pour la fête de la science la
commanderie a décidé de nous parler du
corps sous toutes ses coutures
l'exposition réalisée par l'atelier des
sciences de saint quentin en yvelines
vous propose des tracteurs des
explorations de cornillon il y a une
grande tablette tactile qui s'appelle le
profil aux scop qui propose un dialogue
avec une anthropologue un dialogue
virtuel avec une anthropologue qui vous
permet de constituer le profil
biologique d'un squelette il y a
également une exploration à la loupe du
corps humain pour découvrir des
anecdotes sur le corps humain
on propose également une exploration
mathématiques où le public est invité à
se mesurer toutes ses coutures et
pourquoi pas étudier la divine
proportions une exploration
microscopique avec un microscope
en réalité virtuelle la deuxième partie
n'est pas de tout repos et permet de
découvrir le mouvement
quant à la troisième elle nous plonge
dans le futur il nous parle innovations
dans le domaine de la mobilité et de la
motricité avec par exemple la
présentation d'une maquette
d'exosquelette ton n'est pas juste pour
les enfants mais les enfants apprécient
cette exposition et les adultes aussi où
on a justement essayer d'apporter à la
fois des connaissances pour les adultes
est aussi une découverte plus ludique
pour les enfants
l'exposition est proposée à la
commanderie dès l'âge de 6 ans jusqu'au
25 novembre